bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va
apprendre à faire des cartes mentales la
carte mentale c'est une technique
d'écriture et d'organisation des idées
que vous pouvez utiliser dans de
nombreuses situations par exemple pour
prendre des notes pendant un cours un
exposé ou bien en lisant un livre ou des
articles vous pouvez aussi vous en
servir pour réaliser un bilan ou une
synthèse sur un sujet donné en le
reformulant d'une façon qui vous parle
et enfin les cartes mentales c'est
également très utile comme un outil de
créativité pour organiser toutes vos
idées et potentiellement en trouver de
nouvelles la carte mentale c'est une
méthode dont j'avais parlé dans ma vidéo
sur l'apprentissage et que
personnellement j'utilise tous les jours
depuis des années le problème c'est que
cette technique n'est pas toujours si
simple que ça à appréhender au début et
en plus j'ai l'impression qu'elle n'est
pas forcément toujours bien expliqué
mon but aujourd'hui ça va donc être de
vous présenter cette méthode et de vous
aider à débuter correctement avec si
vous en avez l'envie alors petite alerte
pour les habitués de cette chaîne je
sors un peu de ma ligne habituelle avec
cette vidéo je vais pas parler de
résultats scientifiques ou d'articles de
recherche juste vous partagez des
ressentis un peu plus personnels donc
prenez ça avec un peu de recul bien
Descartes mentale vous en avez
certainement déjà vu ça ressemble à des
schémas arborescents avec un thème
principal au centre et des branches
successives qui irradie vers les bords
on y voit souvent pas mal de couleurs et
des petits dessins un peu partout
et aujourd'hui je vais donc vous
expliquer à la fois les fondements de
cette technique et bien sûr comment on
s'y prend en pratique pour l'utiliser
mais avant ça je voudrais faire une
petite mise en garde sur ce qui me
semble être une mauvaise utilisation des
cartes mentales et qui à mon avis
explique que beaucoup de gens se sentent
déstabilisés vers cette technique je
l'ai dit les cartes mentales c'est super
pour prendre des notes pour synthétiser
pour organiser ses idées mais à mon avis
les cartes mentales ne sont pas un
support de communication elles sont
souvent présentées comme ça on envoie
dans des manuels on vous distribue une
carte mentale qui synthétise un sujet ou
pire elles sont utilisées comme une
sorte d'alternative à des diapops
PowerPoint et à mon avis tous ces usages
comme support de communication
fonctionnent assez mal pour deux raisons
d'une part la communication c'est en
général le linéaire une vidéo un cours
un article qu'on lit il y a un début une
fin une séquence dans le temps la carte
mentale c'est pas le cas il y en a dans
tous les sens et on sait pas toujours
bien par où prendre le sujet
la deuxième raison c'est qu'une carte
mentale c'est un truc très personnel qui
reflète la façon dont chacun voit les
choses donc à mon avis il est très
difficile d'essayer de lire et de bien
comprendre une carte mentale faite par
quelqu'un d'autre une carte mentale on
l'a fait pour soi mais pas pour montrer
ou donner à d'autres évidemment le
paradoxe c'est qu'aujourd'hui pour
illustrer mon propos je vais vous
montrer des cartes mentales que j'ai
faites et vous n'allez pas les trouver
clair ou compréhensibles c'est normal
une carte mentale est un truc personnel
et quand vous ferez les vôtres ça vous
paraîtra tout de suite mieux bien alors
allons-y pour comprendre comment ça
marche l'idée des cartes mentales a été
popularisée dans les années 80 par
l'auteur Tony Buzan et elle est basée
sur l'idée de repenser la façon dont on
écrit dont on note les idées
généralement quand on écrit c'est
linéaire c'est en noir et blanc on fait
plus ou moins des phrases ça prend
plusieurs pages et l'ensemble est assez
uniforme et Buzan propose de faire tout
le contraire une écriture Arbor sur une
seule page qui utilise surtout des mots
clés de la couleur et un maximum de
dessins de symboles en essayant de
forcer les contrastes une façon de
fréquente de comparer écriture
traditionnelle et carte mentale c'est de
faire appel à la fameuse image du
cerveau gauche soit disant analytique et
rationnelle et du cerveau droit
supposément créatif et émotionnel alors
je suis pas fan d'abuser de cette
métaphore des cerveaux droits et gauche
mais il faut reconnaître que l'idée des
cartes mentales par rapport à l'écriture
traditionnelle ça reste effectivement
d'aller taper un peu plus dans la
créativité dans le fun et dans les
émotions
alors pourquoi utiliser cette technique
d’écriture qu'est-ce que ça apporte de
faire comme ça ce que nous dit Tony
Buzan et que moi j'ai ressenti depuis
des années où je l'utilise c'est que la
méthode des cartes mentales serait plus
efficace pour la mémorisation et la
compréhension d'ensemble d'un sujet en
se basant à la fois sur le texte la
couleur le visuel et le dessin à la main
elle va solliciter plusieurs types de
perceptions ce qui est bon pour la
mémorisation et puis surtout la création
d'une carte mentale oblige souvent à
réfléchir sur le contenu et à reformuler
celui-ci à notre façon c'est le principe
de l'apprentissage génératif donc je
parlais dans ma vidéo précédente le fait
de devoir sélectionner synthétiser
réorganiser les idées faire des liens ça
nous permet de mieux comprendre les
concepts et de les mémoriser de façon
plus active et cela aide aussi à mettre
en évidence de nouvelles idées et des
connexions qu'on aurait vu moins
facilement avec une l'écriture linéaire
sur plusieurs pages
et puis aussi on va pas se mentir faire
une carte mentale c'est fun on fait des
petits dessins il y a un plaisir un peu
enfantin à jouer avec les couleurs et
c'est aussi une façon de rester
concentré dans le sujet quand on prend
des notes en écoutant un exposé ou un
cours évidemment pour que ça fonctionne
vous le sentez peut-être les cartes
mentales ça se fait avant tout à la main
alors il y a plein de gens qui vont
essayer de vous vendre des logiciels
pour en faire et pour moi ça va assez
largement à l'encontre des principes
fondamentaux avec un programme de carte
mentale c'est beaucoup plus difficile de
dessiner c'est pas spontané et puis
l'usage de la technologie et du logiciel
crée un obstacle entre notre cerveau et
la carte qu'on essaye de réaliser alors
bien sûr il y a toujours quelques cas
d'usage spécifique mais la majorité du
temps croyez moi faites vos cartes à la
main bien alors passons à la pratique
pour faire une carte mentale il va vous
falloir une feuille blanche pas de ligne
de carreaux au moins au format A4 et
même parfois A3 si vous avez un gros
sujet et que vous avez de la place
et on va prendre cette feuille en format
paysage et c'est normal nos yeux sont
alignés horizontalement c'est le format
naturel pour embrasser un sujet
d'ensemble ensuite il va vous falloir un
stylo bien sûr et des feutres ou des
crayons de couleur alors quelques
couleurs peuvent suffire mais moi j'aime
bien en avoir plein ça ajoute au plaisir
de faire la carte on commence évidemment
avec le thème principal au centre vous
pouvez l'écrire en assez gros mais
essayez tout de suite de l'agrémenter
avec un petit dessin quelques couleurs
pour planter le décor si vous n'avez pas
d'idée faites n'importe quoi en fait
c'est pas très grave ensuite vous allez
faire partir des branches du centre pour
refléter les thèmes principaux
généralement dans le sens des aiguilles
d'une montre mais bon il y a pas de
règle fixe vous pouvez faire des
branches un peu organiques comme un
arbre
si vous réalisez une carte à la main à
partir d'un support écrit un court un
article un livre que vous lisez vous
pouvez créer des branches qui reflètent
les différentes parties du plan existant
mais si vous synthétisez un sujet à être
posé vous pouvez aussi essayer de créer
une structure qui vous parle mieux que
vous trouvez plus logique plus facile à
retenir ensuite vous allez subdiviser
les branches en soubranche en utilisant
des mots clés ça peut être des groupes
de mots mais on évite en général de
faire des phrases écrivez en capital sur
les plus grosses branches et essayer
d'être synthétique ensuite dès qu'on
peut en plus des mots clés on va
compléter avec des petits symboles des
petits dessins et puis de la couleur
pour ajouter des éléments visuels le but
est pas de faire de l'art l'important
c'est de vous créer vos symboles vos
propres codes couleurs qui vous
faciliteront la vue d'ensemble la
mémorisation et les liens entre les
différentes parties au fur et à mesure
que la carte progresse varier les
couleurs les formes créer des contrastes
et surtout essayer de faire des
connexions entre des éléments distants
c'est une les forces des cartes mentales
de bien faire apparaître des liens entre
les différentes parties grâce à la
structure en arbre donc profitez-en au
maximum si vous ne savez pas trop
comment remplir une branche créer des
sous-branches vides posez-vous les
questions usuelles qui ou quand comment
pourquoi et l'important au début n'ayez
pas peur d'y aller franco n'allez pas
vous tromper si vous avez peur de mal
gérer l'espace sur la feuille ou si ça
semble complètement au bordélique en
fait c'est pas grave et souvenez-vous
c'est pas de l'art l'esthétique n'a pas
d'importance il y a pas besoin de savoir
dessiner moi je dessine hyper mal
peut-être que de temps en temps vous
verrez des cartes mentales faites par
d'autres que vous trouverez belle ou
impressionnante mais on s'en fout c'est
vraiment pas le but l'important dans une
carte mentale c'est même pas forcément
le résultat final c'est le processus qui
vous y a amené toutes les connexions et
réflexions que vous avez pu avoir ne
soyez pas dans le jugement en vous
demandant si votre carte est bien si
elle est correcte ou belle l'important
c'est que la démarche vous apporte
quelque chose alors je suis pas du tout
un modèle absolu de création de cartes
mentale mais pour que vous ayez une idée
de comment je m'y prends je vais vous
faire un petit exemple commenté alors je
vais vous montrer un petit exemple où on
va faire une carte à partir qui va être
une synthèse de la fiche Wikipédia du
Japon il me fallait un sujet j'ai pris
ça c'est un peu artificiel comme exemple
mais c'est pour vous montrer l'idée
alors on y va on fait le Japon donc on
commence avec le thème principal au
centre
et puis on l'a dit on va tout de suite
essayer de mettre un peu de visuel là
dessus au Japon facile on fait on fait
un truc qui ressemble vaguement au
drapeau du Japon et puis et puis on va
essayer de dessiner un peu les îles
alors allons-y on va
il y a quoi il y a 4 îles donc c'est pas
grave si c'est pas un reflet exact de la
géographie voilà c'est vraiment juste
pour se donner une petite idée alors les
grands thèmes on va prendre un peu les
grands thèmes pour trouver un peu
toujours dans les différents pays donc
on va prendre par exemple la géographie
on va mettre l'histoire du pays
[Musique]
on va mettre quelque chose autour de
l'organisation politique
peut-être quelque chose sur la
démographie la population
et puis l'économie évidemment
et la culture
alors on va essayer de d'illustrer un
petit peu tout ça l'économie facile on
peut faire des petits des petits billets
verts là comme ça
la population on peut faire des petits
bonhommes
voilà bon là géographie on va on va ça
va ça va parler d'elle-même l'histoire
allez on peut faire une petite flèche un
peu comme une frise voilà on va mettre
des couleurs allez hop on va faire la
géographie on va dire c'est plutôt bleu
l'économie sévère allez hop
et puis voilà on va trouver d'autres
couleurs pour le reste
la politique c'est grillée
la population
et puis la culture la question de
ok alors allons-y là géographie
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qu'on a déjà on
a le fait que
on a des îles au Japon en fait il y en a
plein apparemment il y en aurait plus de
plus de 10000 d'après la page wikipédia
on peut mettre plus de 10000 mais
évidemment vous savez que il y en a
souvent un site les quatre principales
alors on va mettre les principales
alors je note les noms
ok alors si on parle des îles on va
faire un petit symbolisme
comme ça de la mer autour
ok
ensuite allez un élément important c'est
évidemment dans la géographie c'est du
Japon c'est le relief sur la petite
montagne comme ça
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qu'on peut dire sur le sur le
relief on a à la fois des montagnes et
puis il y a aussi un truc c'est que
il y a une activité volcanique on
symbolisait un petit un petit volcan ici
voilà on va parler un peu du climat
un petit nuage et puis un petit un petit
thermomètre
donc le climat en fait il est assez
variable suivant la
latitude apparemment
et donc ça peut aller de d'un climat
plutôt tempéré
vers le nord et puis plutôt
d'eau pour symboliser l'humidité
et puis un élément qui est assez
important c'est le c'est la présence des
je sais pas quoi des petits fonds en
fait
voilà on va parler un peu des des villes
alors les villes facile à faire un petit
une petite représentation avec des
gratte-ciel
qu'est-ce qu'on peut dire bah il y a un
peu toute la toute l'histoire de la
mégalopole là
et puis Tokyo
alors je sais pas j'ai lu Tokyo 14
millions d'habitants allez on va mettre
une petite couleur là dessus
OK
voilà nous pouvons aussi qu'on voit un
peu mentionné peut-être c'est relié aux
villes c'est la
c'est tout ce qui est les
infrastructures
par exemple il y a donc on s'appelle le
Chine
donc c'est des
ok alors on va passer à l'histoire alors
l'histoire l'histoire
on va pas forcément tout détailler mais
bon il y a quelque chose qui en gros
correspondrait à peu près
à l'équivalent un peu occidental de
l'Antiquité il y a la période de la
féodalité
alors qu'est-ce qu'il y a comme date en
gros la féodalité douzième au 16e alors
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire on va faire une
autre couleur
et pour les dates enfin toutes les dates
en orange
ensuite on a cette période qu'on appelle
l'air ça l'air Edo
et do on est plutôt sur du 16e au 19e
donc apparemment les trucs importants
dans cette dans cette période je vais
prendre un crayon un peu plus fin pour
arriver à le noter
c'est que c'est la mise en place de
l'administration
c'est la période du Shogun
et c'est une période plutôt d'isolation
pour pour le Japon apparemment
ok bon prenez pas tout ce que je dis de
toute façon il y a plein de trucs j'ai
mal compris
ensuite on a l'air Medji
et donc ça c'est à partir de 1868 on dit
que les dates en orange on est compté
voilà 1868
et donc là c'est le moment où
on a l'Empire on a
aussi une de l'expansionnisme
alors on peut faire un petit on peut se
faire un petit contraste avec
l'isolation qu'on a mentionné de tout à
l'heure et on va choisir une couleur
donc en fait l'expansionnisme on va le
représenter comme ça allez hop
et l'isolation dans
ce que je fais mais c'est pas grave
et puis donc on a aussi un contrat entre
le shogun et l'Empire donc on va
peut-être utiliser
un médecin en jaune un peu comme la
couronne des monarques
le shogun et l'Empire pour bien
comprendre que on est passé d'un régime
à l'autre
on a évidemment un élément important
c'est la deuxième guerre mondiale
avec un peu 12 éléments pour le pour le
Japon on a tout ce qui concerne le
conflit avec la Chine alors on va
dessiner la Chine
donc en rouge et puis avec un peu de
jaune là
le conflit avec la Chine
et puis il y a le conflit du Pacifique
avec les États-Unis
allez on va dessiner les États-Unis je
peux très bien comment on fait le
drapeau rouge
avec un peu de bleu
voilà
et puis évidemment un élément qu'on peut
pas passer sous silence c'est
la bombe atomiques on va laisser la
présenter
on va faire un petit champignon
et puis on peut terminer par la période
contemporaine
et là
en fait c'est
à la fois une période de au début de
tutelle
américaine
et puis aussi une période de
reconstruction
par exemple il y a un élément qui est
assez symbolique c'est le
JO de Tokyo en 64 alors on va faire
Tokyo
les cercles olympiques ça va être
totalement au pif
je suis un peu sûr d'avoir les bonnes
couleurs mais bon c'est pas grave
important
voilà
bon en gros je vais m'arrêter là j'ai à
peu près mis un ensemble d'informations
qui étaient les éléments qu'on trouvait
les grands éléments qu'on retrouve sur
la page wikipédia et ça nous donne un
espèce de portrait de ce qui avait dans
cette dans cette page alors encore une
fois on aurait pu la faire différemment
on aurait pu la faire plus grande pour
mettre plus d'éléments mais voilà donc
première approche ce que ça peut donner
voilà c'était en gros comment je m'y
prends pour faire des cartes mentales et
c'est un outil que j'utilise énormément
pour apprendre des nouvelles choses pour
organiser mes idées sur un sujet sur
lequel je travaille et notamment bien
sûr pour préparer mes vidéos
je m'en sers quand je lis en jonglant
entre plusieurs sources ou que j'essaye
de reformuler à ma sauce ce qui explique
à un article quand je dois synthétiser
etc je m'en sers aussi beaucoup pour
prendre des notes dans des exposés ou
des présentations scientifiques ou pas
d'ailleurs ça me permet de rester dans
le sujet de moins décrocher d'avoir des
notes synthétiques et puis de griffonner
de façon fun et agréable si jamais je
m'ennuie voilà donc mon conseil pour
vous lancer dans la technique c'est
d'essayer appliquer les règles mais sans
prise de tête et sans vous soucier trop
de ce à quoi ça ressemblera à la fin il
faut lâcher prise parfois le fait de
faire une carte mentale vous éclairera
sur un sujet et vous aurez envie de la
reprendre immédiatement pour la refaire
différemment alors ça peut arriver mais
ça doit pas non plus être l'objectif ni
passez pas des heures
tester la méthode en espérant que ça
vous soit utile pour les études le
travail ou dans la vie de tous les jours
et si vous ne la trouvez pas bénéfique
pour vous c'est rien passé à autre chose
et souvenez-vous ces cartes que je vous
montre si vous n'arrivez pas à les
comprendre ou à les lire c'est normal
c'est pas fait pour créer vos propres
cartes et utiliser les mais laissez
celles des autres ou elles sont voilà
c'est tout pour aujourd'hui promis la
prochaine fois on revient à de la vraie
science abonnez-vous ça n'est pas déjà
le cas rejoignez le serveur discord de
science étonnante je vous mets le lien
en description et je vous dis à très
vite pour de nouvelles vidéos à bientôt
[Musique]